Oh
how's it going red my name is welcome to
fairness this game was made by Quantic
Dream's it's the same developers of
heavy rain which I know a lot of us
loved I love that game so much I never
played this game I played heavy rain
when I lights played it so it's gonna be
more fun for me as well haha sorry umm
and then my reaction should be more
I don't know fading I don't [ __ ] know
what's interesting is that it says new
movie instead of new game so that should
give you an idea of what they were going
for when making this and you bros seem
to like story based games for sure so
I'm more than happy to bring it to you
this game is relatively unknown I know a
lot of people still know about it but I
think in comparison to how good it
actually is or how well ruined I
received it as it's kind of sad that
more not so many people know about it or
I've seen it that being said let's just
[ __ ] play it tutorial that's our
[ __ ] alright let's go for a new game
I'm kidding I already did a tutorial
alright Rosalie's that means it's gonna
be dramatic and [ __ ]
Quantic Dream that means it's gotta be
[ __ ] dramatic overload it's true and
you know it
freakin French people they're crazy
things are never quite what they seem I
agree with you think we understand the
world around us but we really really
only see the outside I know what you're
saying is to be I used to be just like
you oh really I believed in human
the newspapers I don't believe so
commercials politics and history books
one day the world kicks you in the teeth
and you don't have any choice but to see
things the way they really are
ah my name is Lukas Cade I own my story
is the one where an ordinary guy has
something extraordinary happened to him
maybe it was supposed to happen maybe it
was my destiny or nearly both become
diamond whatever I know one thing for
sure now that nothing's ever going to be
the same again oh they're magic I love
it all right
Fahrenheit well so far so good they sure
know how to make it sorry interesting
what what is this it all started right
here where else could it happen [ __ ]
New York New York capital blast yeah all
right yes bored destiny chose for my
guest big game I was just another pawn
living my pawns life I could can put up
some titles my dad nothing work and my
life descended into chaos is that a
rocket ship
and that
that is in Statue of Liberty why of
course hello there lady all right cool I
never actually been in New York I was
gonna go there a couple years ago when
that volcano erupted in Iceland so they
blocked up all the airports so we
couldn't go it's quite the shame but hey
what can you do well we see a crow we
know what that means we play no [ __ ] ha
ha that guy's gonna die [ __ ] no I like
her this is starting it's [ __ ] creepy
how long can he piss seriously up holy
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] I hope it doesn't cut off
his penis that's really bad if you do
that
that that crow jump-scare what the [ __ ]
okay
ah dad we're gonna oh are we gonna kill
him
nah ah I'm sorry
oh this is like Lucia's all and over
again what the [ __ ] how can he not see
him in the mirror are you serious
there's a zombie behind you bro wha did
he miss did you get him did we get him
I think we get him excuse me sir Edward
a parricide you're quite not dead yet
let me fix that for you all right just
stand completely still this will only
hurt a lot he doesn't mean look ah oh
this is disturbing
I'm fabulous hahaha ah - mysterious girl
reminds him Silent Hill or some [ __ ]
like that
hey girl what's your name you won't tell
us anything about you
you will appear later in the game and
still be mysterious I'm super fabulous
oh we wake up
what what what have I done what is this
we're depressed oh no we were so happy a
minute ago at crow I didn't want
drew it was not a dream it's real
oh we have to escape but there's a cop
that son of a [ __ ]
quick I got to get out of here before
somebody comes in here cool
well I like the main character he seems
pretty cool oh yeah you're controlled
with the arrow keys and the mouse it's a
little weird but hey [ __ ] works what
can we do with this guy oh and I click
like left the right to push him up luck
let's flush him down the toilet and that
makes me less depressed now I'm anxious
all right I am that's a little weird but
I'll take it
can we can we go out the window a
plateau it's barred up I can't get out
this way all right I'm gonna point out
again oh [ __ ] that makes me more
different I'm depressed now I can't do
anything about the subtitles your day
game doesn't have them what do you want
made it out all right
so up and down make it clean this makes
me happy
put you away all right now we have to do
what I've been waiting a long time to do
thank God finally oh yeah I just killed
a man but you know nature has snow I
don't know what did they call in English
not toad and hunting in no law all right
handsome as always in blood I can't go
anywhere looking like this well that's
out of order how about you pick the
other one that doesn't say out of order
that's nice leave your fingerprints all
over that place silly man doesn't know
what to do
all right we're a little happier now is
there something else we can do smoke a
cigarette what is this oh it's so one
thing I've got to get rid of it oh [ __ ]
what's happening
but why did I put it in my bud okay well
I guess that's it I guess we're ready to
go
is that a condom dispenser hey all right
just walk cool pity poker face I can't
kill anyone and do anything but I'm an
asset
all right let's go sir ha I'm an actress
I didn't kill her I swear to God I had
to kill yes yes I think that you might
have forgotten to pay your bill oh of
course I oh excuse me
the bill for the meal how could I forget
that quick before somebody finds the
body okay so I can't leave anyway where
where is it my did was said over here
alright let's pay it it's pretty simple
control I like it a lot more than heavy
rain it's heavy rain I don't know it
just doesn't work very well in my
opinion would I need to get out of this
neighborhood before the police get here
ok oh [ __ ] the cops is coming I did it
run what's going on here
what am I am I going over here what's up
hmm looks homeless nah [ __ ] you battle
guy hoping this freezing cold the hell
am I supposed to go then
uh-oh I like how the angle wow this is
beautiful
it works well usually when they have two
winners they're rendering like an
oceanic art can we find a [ __ ] cab or
some [ __ ] like that
oh shut up
we better hurry oh hello nobody goes
anywhere a crime has just been committed
I'm going to have to Eggman say come and
wait here for the police
Brooklyn please Brooklyn all right
oh is that the homeless guy oh [ __ ] it's
gonna tell on us son of a [ __ ] Oh
creepy I like it so far it's awesome
- ten degrees are you kidding me that is
[ __ ] cold aimin for Sweden docks
dining that's it why do they always wait
for me to go on duty before they stop
killing each other in the middle of the
night I'm a tiger Charlie gets murdered
every day in New York really especially
when I'm on night duty it's as if every
psycho in the city has an informant
someone gets murdered every day all
right that way I don't have to freeze to
death
listening to it ha you're the boss Carla
it's really that many murderer rounders
all right so I guess this girl it's like
Madison Paige how's it going McCarthy
evening inspector I've been waiting for
like oh I like both the main characters
hey Pam not racist what happened don't
like homicide I found the body in the
toilets I had to go before I went home
where there would anybody notice
anything strange no nobody saw anything
well I have a sister sign a client left
just before I found the body well which
Tim wasn't killed with a blade from what
I could gather but we should wait for
the autopsy huh I always wonder how they
say that word Oh table was a suspect
sitting it uh he was sitting at that
table over there hmm
he was having some enchilada that's
wonderful bodies still there the boys
from the morgue were waiting for you to
get here before moving it all right get
nobody's been in the toilets since we
found the body well I'm right waitress
over there yeah Cate Morrison I think
that you should interrogate her if you
don't mind me saying girl don't tell me
how to do my job she's still in a state
of shock thanks for help are ttan it's
late I think hey thanks for your help
Marty wait until you're finished with
Kate if you don't mind
well I'm sure she gets home okay oh you
just want to [ __ ] her be honest all
right what did I say at present
okay I can press switch character well
that's kind of cool I guess don't really
know why I need that feature but let's
run over to this girl
Kate I'm inspector Carla Valenti I'm in
charge of the investigation here which
are like quite a few questions
no go ahead
okay spill the [ __ ] I know it's you can
you tell me anything about the customer
who left just before they discovered the
body it was just a normal guy I didn't
really pay any attention to it
god dammit woman count me marked and
well John was a regular is he doing he
came every Monday he always ordered the
same thing and that's a nice tip he left
a nice Ted well what about this
description do you think you could
describe him for me I only saw him for a
few seconds I guess he was about average
height fairly young that's all I can
remember god damn you're hopeless well
what about his behavior doing before the
murder happened he was there for a while
he was reading I think
it was reading I wasn't reading but it
he gets motive him had any enemies
anybody that might want to kill him John
was just a nice normal guy I can't see
why anybody would want to kill him
maybe he's ugly he looks pretty ugly and
he peed really in fashion that John and
the suspect knew each other no I don't
think they didn't know each other
the man had already been here a while
when John came in they didn't talk to
each other no I'm almost certain that
John didn't know him okay well what the
[ __ ] then can you tell me what you saw
they want that many people tonight it's
usually pretty calm during the week
uh-huh I was just chatting with Martin
at the bar I didn't even see John get up
god damn you sighs well let's cheer I'll
try to be strong Kate be strong this has
been a shot for you but you're the only
one who can help us find suspect
my shift was almost over I was just
chatting with Martin at the bottom yeah
you told us that strife went to the
restroom the man must have fallen when
he came back out I noticed that he
hadn't paid his bill
I'm kiff because that happens a lot here
people forgetting to pay the bill Oh
what happened next the man came back he
paid his bill and left it wasn't until
Martin found John's body oh he liked our
son well did you hear anything while
John was in the toilets sound of a
struggle
no I didn't notice anything well was
junk if I want to notice anything
strange about John tonight
did he seem worried or stressed out no
he was just like he always is he even
made a joke when he came in do you think
that you would recognize the suspect
I'll never forget that face oh [ __ ] I
was that beautiful huh do you think that
you could come down to the station
tomorrow and help us construct a
likeness if you can better do it
otherwise I kill you yeah again I'll do
whatever you think I can to help catch
him thank you very much for your help
Kate thank you so much
doing so helpful bastard who did it
people like that just don't deserve to
live I promise you we'll do everything
in our power to find him go home and try
to get to all right so you can kind of
when you get home okay kind of notice
the story is similar to heavy rain al
similarities as well at least god damn
is [ __ ] but yeah I like it it's kind of
like futuristic and all at the same time
if that makes sense all sort of it kind
of dark [ __ ] ups to worry about
murderers and [ __ ] all right
so am I supposed to talk to these
douchebags what's up hey Garrett hey
Frank how's it going hey Carla hey Carla
Hey find anything
we took some samples here and there
we're almost finished we were just
waiting for you before we took the body
away
Oh odd you see let's take a look all
right let's take a look at the body then
whatever the [ __ ] that is sit here
all right car car oh oh so he comes with
us
all right let's investigate the murder
see sleeping on the toilet huh in the
area of the heart they appear to be
knife wounds disgraceful all right maybe
we should have the this guy I don't know
his name check it out too bizarre what
well he still has his credit card and a
hundred bucks in cash on it how did he
see that just by looking at it was money
how did he see that just like that you
know what are we gonna do oh you can do
it okay
hey would learn what's up I'm this piece
is a restroom I come out what's up girl
it's cool dusting all that cost gas and
drinking to try and stay away okay
that's stressed Carla the thought of
okay I'm sorry girl I'm sorry again
you know what I'll watch my hand
actually you know what I'm not gonna
watch my head haha
that's disgusting
well I don't think we left any [ __ ]
evidence so it's kind of hard to look
for it I mean we're just too good at
killing people Brea's oh he can check
the trash but not the girl are you
serious just what exactly are you doing
Tyler I'm checking for clues what do you
think okay so that's kind of interesting
yeah what is he doing
there's no clues there bro maybe you can
check the toilet
I mean you check the other things yeah
you can check the toilet that's nice of
you to flush so they can do different
stuff do you know someone is contacted
to family oh I heard something I'll take
you away the gang running around hiding
bloody knives and toilets I think I
might have found the murder weapon whoa
good job Tyler tonight I haven't checked
for prints on the handle okay okay
there's [ __ ] prints everywhere all
right I guess that's it that's it for
today brass come on I'm tired I just
want to let it go Tyler I think I've
seen everything I need to see are you
sure we can take another look around if
you want come on before you were [ __ ]
out complain we're good let's at home
okay let's bust still uh get back to the
car let's button day buddy
let's brushless specialist bus left
first left later noobs
ah ah sorry all right
yeah
I press [ __ ] epic game so far I think
it's gonna be an interesting story I
hope your brothers will tag along on
dish like a beta version joy absolute a
lot since it's a new serious and you
know you want people if you want to I'm
just saying you don't have to but yeah
alright stay awesome bros and i'll keep
making that is look at that crows ass
beautiful
brofist [ __ ]
holy
how is it is here zombie we still alive
what the [ __ ]
okay now I'm just [ __ ] [ __ ] creep
dad alright professor I guess
never ever
oh good